Hello, everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Decent. I'm your host, Ricardo Loops. And today I'm
joined by Doctor Lydia Moland. She's a professor of
Philosophy at Colby College in Waterville Maine in the
US. She has written extensively on 19th century German
philosophy. And more recently, she has also been interested
in abolitionism in the US. And she wrote a
book titled Lydia Maria Child, a Radical American Life
based on the American evolutionist with the same name.
So, Doctor Moland, welcome to the show. It's a
big pleasure to everyone.
Thank you. It's a pleasure to be invited and
I'm looking forward to our conversation.
OK. So, uh I would like to start by
talking about your work on 19th century German philosophy.
So, first of all, why did you get interested
specifically in 19th century German philosophy? And do you
think that if anything, there's uh specific aspects of
it that make it distinct from other kinds of
philosophy, from other places and other time periods?
Yes. Thank you for that. Um I got interested
in German 19th century philosophy through Spinoza. So I
took a very general philosophy course as an undergraduate.
Uh AND I had intended to be a political
science major, but I read Spinoza and it just
blew my mind and I, I was so moved
by the vision that Spinoza had of holism and
of um and, and the way he argued that
I decided to do more philosophy and ended up
in a course that ended with Kant. And I
think as many people do finished with some very
deep dissatisfactions with Kant's dualism and with his rationalism.
And someone said to me, well, if you are
impatient with Kant, maybe you should try Hegel. Uh
So the next semester, I took a course on
the Phenomenology of Spirit and then I was just
hooked. Um AND I ended up going to Tubingen
in Germany where Hegel himself studied, I lived there
for a couple of years and really immersed myself
in the culture of that particular time period. So
many of your viewers will know that Tubing in
is also where Holderlin lived and studied and also
shelling. So Hagel was there in this incredibly fertile
environment where people were taking very seriously. Spinoza was
still essentially forbidden. He was still considered too controversial
and too heretical to take seriously. But they were
all sort of closet spin assists. And um I,
I found all of that very intriguing. I think
what, what really pulled me into Hagel was his
attempt to make philosophical sense of religion and of
protestantism. In particularly I came from a protestant background
and was really intrigued by his attempt to show
what was important and vital about the protestant worldview
without attaching it to a kind of uh religious
literalism. Um So that was, that was very helpful
to me, even just in thinking through my own
philosophical questions. So as far as what makes that
period distinct, um a couple of things come to
mind, again, sort of connected to Spinoza. I think
the, again, this idea of holism, the attempt not
to think of philosophy as just addressing one problem
or focusing on just epistemology or just in the
physics. But the idea that an idea could possibly
explain kind of everything. Um I think characterizes a
lot of early 19th century philosophy in Germany, certainly
not later. But sometimes when I teach students this,
I find that, that, that claim is really strange
to them that there could be one answer or
one idea that could explain everything. But I sometimes
push back on that and say, wouldn't it be
even stranger if different parts of the reality or
of philosophy were totally unconnected from each other? I
wouldn't it be sort of strange if nature functions
in a completely different way from art or from
politics or from epistemology? So, isn't there something even
just more intellectually consistent about looking for an idea
that could explain most of human experience and maybe
even nonhuman experience? So that's one another, I think
a lot of really existential questions get started in
the 19th century. So you see that some in
Kant for sure. But I think it took this
generation of thinkers who grew up in the French
revolution, which meant that everything they thought they knew
about the way politics could and should work were
um was, was challenged. And then there were great
hopes around the French revolution and then they were
dashed. And so this was a generation that really
grew up feeling the existential weight of a major
historical disappointment if you were a young person in
that generation. Um And, and so the combination I
think of K turn towards the subject, which really
gives an individual subject an enormous amount of power.
And therefore, also responsibility opens up these big existential
questions and then living in this part of history
where there are enormous shifts um that ask questions
like what is the role of politics and what
is the role of the individual in politics? And
how do individuals assert themselves in the face of
great historical forces? Um Those set the stage for
the kinds of grappling with, what does it mean
to be an individual? What does it mean to
be alienated in a society? Um Obviously something that's
been picked up by Marx and then more by
Kirkegaard and Nietzsche later in the century. Um And
then I would also say, and, and this is
clearly in part because of my own work, a
real reorientation around art and around aesthetic experience. So
that certainly gets started in Kant with his taking
seriously aesthetic experience is one of the most important
things about human experience. Um But then when you
get to people like Hegel, but also very much
his contemporaries like Lael or Novalis, Bettina von Ar
Carlina Von Gunder Rode. Um SOME of these other
people who saw in art and then also in
nature and our aesthetic responses to nature, really central
truths about the human condition. Then I, I think
you get something very interesting that lasts throughout the
century in part because I think one way I
try to think about it is the question, what
if art far from being derivative or entertaining or
the thing that we can philosophize about kind of
if we get to it? What if instead it
is the thing, the thing that that can explain
us to ourselves and the world to ourselves better
than other branches of philosophy. If that's true, then
a lot of things need to be revolved um
sort in any kind of revolution so that I'll
stop there. But those are a couple of the
things that I find really compelling and possibly um
I don't know, unique but certainly indicative of that
period in that place in the world.
OK. So I have to tell you straight away
that the three German philosophers whose work I'm most
familiar with are Kent Nietzsche and Schopenhauer. So uh
probably because of some of my personality traits. I
don't know exactly why, but those are the three
I felt most compelled about. And, uh, I mean,
but, uh, of course, I guess that we could
pretty much say that, uh, everyone in the 19th
century in German was to some extent influenced by
Kent. Right? I mean, even the ones who rejected
most of his philosophy or some, or parts of
his philosophy, like for example, Schopenhauer and Nietzsche, Nietzsche,
to a greater extent, even them were very, very
much influenced by Kent. I, I think we could
and of course, uh I mean, it's not that
German philosophy in the 19th centuries is a monolith,
like for example, sometimes people talk about German idealism,
but I mean, you get into figures like Schopenhauer
and Nietzsche and they were extremely different from can
or what you would consider just general idealism. Nietzsche
particularly sometimes is classified as a romantic or rationalist
and he certainly rejected many aspects of Kent's philosophy.
And Schopenhauer was very much a pessimist for example.
So, uh but I mean, do you think that
we could look uh even with those differences? And
of course, we could talk about the other philosophers
and they certainly have m many distinct things about
their philosophical corpus, I think. But uh do you
think that e even with all of those differences
and existentialism also that I didn't mention and all
of that, that we can still find recurrent themes
in 19th century German philosophy.
Yeah, I mean, I, I think one really is
the struggle with the nature of subjectivity and what
it means. Epistemological, metaphysically, politically, aesthetically. Uh What does
it mean to be a self? And like if
you think not to oversimplify, but if you think
about someone like Descartes just saying, well, the self
is a thinking thing. It's essentially an immaterial substance.
Um ITS essence is just to think and it
subsists as a thinking thing. Um You know, a
quick contrast to Kant, I think is Kant's idea
of this self as an activity. So as something
that is actively synthesizing whatever is coming at it
and that it only achieves selfhood through being active.
And I think in a way, one of the
questions that survives all the way through the century
then is um what kind of activity is that?
And what does the basis of thinking through subjectivity?
Um MEAN for objectivity and for reality and for
how we treat other people and obviously paired with
that is the question of whether there is a
transcendent divine that humans are beholden to or created
by and who dictates reality as we see it.
And in my opinion, Hagel, for instance, is trying
very hard to reorient us from that to seeing
that humans are the only creators of meaning and
that we only create meaning in cooper operation with
each other. So there's, if you think about kind
as primarily thinking of the subject as activity. Hagel,
I think picks that up but with a much
stronger emphasis on the kind of mutual recognition that's
necessary to think about my being a subject is
dependent on your recognizing me as a subject. And
only when we recognize each other, not just abs
as abstract subjects, but as subjects embodied in different
roles and different areas of history, different life plans.
Can we really treat each other with the dignity
and respect that Kant had originally said we owed
each other. And so I think like if you
follow that trajectory out um and start to think
about like Kirke guards grappling with what it meant
to be a subject kind of at odds with
um with the conventional world or norms that were
established by a society that he didn't feel um
acknowledged by. And then someone like Nietzsche, who I
think is even more expressly celebrating the agony and
the ecstasy of being a self creating subject. So
I think in, in Nietzsche much more than in
Hegel, you get again the existential. Yeah, I'll say
it again, agony and ecstasy of the fact that
we have to create our own meaning where we
can't rely on the divine or on nature as
something separate from us to tell us what is
meaningful, we have to do it ourselves. And that
um is a great privilege and honor, but also
an enormous responsibility that I think in Nietzsche's view
more than in Hagel's only some people are really
up to shouldering. So in, in each of them,
you get the sense that lots of people would
just really rather prefer to have others tell them
what is meaningful. Um And our calling is to
resist that. I think Hagel, for instance, is much
less interested in that kind of resistance and more
interested in trying to think of ourselves as a
cooperating group of people, each with our own subjectivities.
But working out our subjectivity and our bid for
freedom very much with each other as opposed to
in the kind of individualistic way that you get
with Nietzsche.
That subjectivity part. I mean, what I'm going to
say now, if I say something that you don't
agree with or you think is incorrect, please correct
me. But uh I mean, of course, in someone
like Nietzsche and is to some extent, perspect perspective
is philosophy because he, he particularly in beyond good
and evil, for example. And when and when it
comes to morality more specifically, there, there are places
in his work where he expresses a very uh
perspective perspective on, on things uh uh and things
seem to be very dependent on the subject and
subjectivity. But uh I mean, uh don't you think
that even in Kent, particularly when uh in the
critic of purism, he talks about, for example, the
limits of, of our uh o of the information
we can get from our senses, the uh th
those kinds of limits and, and also the fact
that we uh sort of uh have some sort
of categories of understanding. And I think that some
of them, they, it takes from, I guess Aristotle,
if I'm not mistaken and expands on them, I
mean, the a and then the, and then also
when he gets into the, the antinomy and he
talks about the things that even as through a
reasoning process cannot fully answer. Like for example, if
there's life after death, if there's a God, if
the universe is infinite in time and space questions
like that. Uh I, I mean, that isn't there,
even if only a tiny seed of subjectivity planted
there because I mean, it seems that there's the
thing in itself or whatever reality is and then
our own limitations as human subjects when it comes
to perceiving it and getting an objective understanding of
what it is. I, I mean, I, I don't
know, what are your thoughts on this?
Yeah, absolutely. I think that's 100% right? And I
think that's a kind of radical postulate that I
don't even think Kant felt the existential weight of
which is to say it took someone. Well, I,
I, I'm much more familiar with the early romantics,
you know, the Schlegel and, and Schelling and, and
Novalis and Gunter Rode and people like that who
took that. I, I just feel like much more
to heart and as you say, I think it
is partly dispositional or generational that, you know, can
have laid those things out fairly matter of factly.
But I think that the consequences for how we
think about our role in, on our responsibility in
the world and the radical perspect nature of that,
as you say, um was really exhilarating and upsetting
to more to the next generation of thinkers.
So getting into Hegel and specifically, of course, you've
already said a few things about him, but getting
specifically to into aesthetics because when we think about
Hegel, I mean, people who are not philosophers and
not specifically very familiar with Hegel's philosophy, we tend
to just think about his more systematic and abstract
approaches to history and uh uh thesis, antithesis synthesis
and stuff like that. But he also in fact
wrote about aesthetics.
Yes. And that was part of his system for
sure. So um aesthetics is the first part of
absolute spirit. So if you think of, of, you
know, the system writ large, you've got um you
know, subjective spirit and the first you have logic
and then you have philosophy of nature and then
in philosophy of spirit, you first have subjective spirit
and then objective spirit and then absolute spirit. Absolute
spirit is where Hagel talks about the three ways
that he thinks humans grapple with what it means
to be human. So the ways in which we
reflect on um on the world, but also on
our role in the world. So the first of
those is art and then religion and then being
a philosopher, Hagel always has philosophy win at the
end. So philosophy for Hagel is still the best
um most complete and most explicit way that humans
reckon with their um their own status and ask
themselves about meaning in the world. But art has
a really important place in that for Hagel because
we are embodied sensual beings. And contrary to what
some people think about Hagel, he doesn't regret that.
I mean, it isn't that if we could, we
should get rid of that part of ourselves. I
think he thinks that that's a very rich and
very vital way in which humans remain part of
the natural world. So we continue to feel and
smell and hear things um that are outside of
us. But we also use our senses to create
things that then mean something to us and that
reflect our own grappling with that meaning. So I
think that for Hegel, aesthetics is the sensuous way
of experiencing truth. So truth for Hegel again, back
to Spinoza is this very holistic view of the
identity of identity and difference. So he says the
true is the whole, it's the thing that brings
together contraries and this is where people get the
thesis sis synthesis um theme that you just referred
to. And so art is the way that we
can sense that truth through our senses as opposed
to understanding it through narratives, which is the way
Hegel characterizes religion. So interestingly, religion for him is
primarily about narrative stories that we tell ourselves to
explain everything from the origin of the world to
um you know, our own relationship to each other
through. And then philosophy is supposed to do that
without narrative and without our senses. So just through
thought. So then within aesthetics, Hagel's project is to
say how art does that and which kinds of
art and which particular instances of art do that
best? So for him, the question always is, is
this particular art form or this particular artwork allowing
us to sense the idea which is the unity
of unity and division or the true? That is
the whole. So he does this um in a
couple of ways. Um One by giving what some
people call the first really philosophical history of art.
I always think people are too quick to assign
first to anything and usually when they do that,
it's to a male European philosopher. And I think
that is often not true. So I try to
be skeptical about that. Um BUT whether he was
first or not, he certainly had a very influential
idea of the sort of history and progress of
art. So that's in what's part two of his
lectures on the philosophy of art. And then he
has a whole part three and I'm happy to
get into it. This is one of my major
claims in my book on Hagel's aesthetics is that
part three has been essentially neglected by HGL scholars.
But that's where he talks about what he calls
individual arts, which are architecture, sculpture, painting, music, and
poetry. Importantly, in that order, because that's the order
in which Hagel thinks he can explain how humans
increasingly come to take ownership of their own um
art. So I'm happy to talk about that later.
But anyway, so that's that in general um is
where aesthetics and the philosophy of art fits in
Hegel's system. And the, the other big claim that
I make in my book on Hagel's aesthetics is
that we learn so much about Hagel's idealism through
his aesthetics. So it's not just that OK, we
get Hagel's system and then when we have time,
we can do the aesthetics. But if we don't
understand the aesthetics, we don't understand really crucial things
about Hagel's theory of selfhood, about feeling about perception,
like things that, that people usually talk about under
the heading of, you know, metaphysics or epistemology. Um
But I think there's a lot to learn about
those more traditional fields. Um Well, see, I shouldn't
even say traditional fields because that, that wasn't the
case in Hegel's generation that people thought that metaphysics
and epistemology were like the core philosophical um enterprises
and aesthetics was just derivative really the opposite. Um
So it's more because of the way philosophy developed,
especially in the early 20th century that we've come
to think that um again, so part of what
I'm, what I try to do here is, is,
is reorient us towards thinking about it the other
way.
So there's something that you mentioned there that I
would like to get more into. So, and, and
please correct me if I'm wrong. But it seems
then that in a way uh the way Hegel
approaches aesthetics, I mean, it's not as some sort
of a separate field or domain from all the
other domains of philosophy, like epistemology, probably ethics and
metaphysics because uh I mean, isn't it also that
as Hegel uh understands art and aesthetics more generally,
that it ties very much to epistemology for example,
and how we understand the world and how we
acquire knowledge about it.
Absolutely. Yeah, absolutely. So we don't, there are things
that we can only sort of know through our
senses. So that's an epistemological question. And there are
ways in which our status as embodied beings can
only be known to us through our senses. And
so if we don't talk about art, we're not
talking about a key part of epistemology. And I
think that Hagel has a pretty clear sense that
our senses are, uh again, it's not, sometimes people
think that Hagel thinks that we'd be best if
we were disembodied and I just think that's absolutely
false. Um So, in so far as part of
what we know is embodied and there is such
a thing as embodied knowledge, this is where we
get it, we get it through aesthetics. And I
should say, you know, strangely, especially coming after Kant
and Shelling Hegel is completely uninterested in natural beauty.
Like he just doesn't even really want to talk
about it. Um He, he is almost exclusively interested
in the philosophy of art and in aesthetics as
an artistic phenomenon. Um But other people have certainly
talked a lot more about our aesthetic appreciation of
nature. And Schiller is a great example of that.
And it's always been very surprising to me that
Hagel doesn't engage with that conversation in Schiller more
than he does. Um But yes, absolutely. Um So
like to give you an example when he talks
about music, music for Hegel is the way we
sense time. And if you think about Kant, talking
about time is one of the two oper intuitions
through which that is necessary to our understanding the
world and having experience at all. For Hegel. Music
is the thing that in the, in the most
pure sense allows us to sense time and since
time is so critical to selfhood, so there's no
selfhood without time in a way. He thinks that
music allows us to sense the self. I mean,
it doesn't get more root epistemological and metaphysical than
that. So what, what music allows us to do
is have this very pure sense of what is
so purely part of our existence, namely time. And
that Hagel thinks is why music literally moves us,
I mean, literally and metaphorically. So you can be
moved by music emotionally. But Hagel himself says that
sometimes without knowing it, we'll start tapping our feet
when or moving our body. I love that image
of Hagel it like, you know, we tended to
give him as such a serious German philosopher and
he was. But um but he himself recognizing that
sometimes he couldn't help but move, you know, that
that's really uh deep, deep knowledge of ourselves. And
again, the knowledge without which I think Hagel thinks
our own understanding of ourselves would be impoverished.
That's all very interesting. I mean, oo one of
the things that I find fascinating about some philosophers
is that nowadays through science, we are confirming some
of their ideas or intuitions, things that they've arrived
at uh without uh II, I mean, not through
science as at least as we understand it today,
of course. But for example, when you were talking
there about uh embodiment and embodied knowledge, I mean,
nowadays, we have an entire field of embodied cognition
and how we acquire knowledge through, not just through
operations that occur in our brain, but through our
brain being connected to the rest of our body
and how we move in the world and the
actions we do and how we interact with things.
And I, I mean, it's really fascinating to me
and uh I mean, as I said, I'm more
familiar with people like Nietzsche, but even Nietzsche, we
could say was very much a philosopher of action.
I mean, he, he loved to walk a lot
and thinking while he was walking and he talked
about doing philosopher, philosophy with a hammer and, and
they very much admire people of action. And I,
I mean, doing things instead of just sitting and
thinking and have this sort of more platonic vision
of things that perhaps we could or should in
a way try to disembody ourselves, which in a
way seems very, uh, uh, II, I mean, uh,
the, there's a very interesting caricature of that. I,
I don't know if you ever watched the movie,
The Adventures Of Baron Munchausen. But there's a, there's
a scene there played by Robin Williams where he's,
uh, uh, the king of the moon. I think
it's the king of the moon, but the man
on the moon and he can separate his head
from the rest of the body just to try
to become more enlightened and it doesn't really work.
So I think it's a very, uh, a very
funny parody of that sort of, uh disembodied idea
of nationality or epistemology. So, yeah.
Yeah. And I do think that Hagel, despite his
reputation, also resisted that kind of reification of reason
and of the mind. Um, AND, you know, there's
a lot of that in his philosophy of subjective
spirit too when he talks about anthropology and um
in psychology and ways in which our minds are
very formed by what happens around us. And it
talks about insanity in those passages as being very
much tied to our embodied um existence. So there's,
there's way more of that in HGL than most
people think. And again, I think the aesthetics are
a wonderful way to get at that. I mean,
I'll, I'll say one other thing about it. I
think part of what Hagel really appreciated about art
is that we go through our everyday lives, sensing
things, but not being aware that we're sensing them.
So not being aware of ourselves as seeing and
as hearing and as touching. And when we do
that, I think Hagel thinks we risk beginning to
treat the world as something that's just out there
that's a given. You know, so mcdowell and Brandon
have been talking about this for a very long
time. Mcdowell, especially the myth of the given, right?
So the world is out there and what epistemology
is, is just our, like attaching our ideas to
the outside world in uh in an accurate way.
And I think Hagel thinks that that that happens
in part just out of habit, of course. So
when I walk by a tree, I can't every
time think, wow, I'm seeing a tree. And even
though, you know, it seems this way from this
perspective, it's actually a different way from that. Like
I'd never get through my day. Um But what
art does is remind us of what our senses
are doing by disrupting that in really interesting ways.
So, and one example would be looking at a
painting and realizing that I can see three dimensions
where there aren't three dimensions. And that tells me
something about the interaction of my mind with the
world. So we might think of a painting is
a paradigmatic example of something that just exists independently
outside of us. But actually for it to exist
as a painting, there has to be someone looking
at it and perceiving it in a certain way.
And Hagel thinks that that kind of mutual formation
between the self and the world actually is what
is true of us all day, every day. But
we get used to it, it becomes and this
is a really important technical term for him. Prosaic,
right? We start to treat it as just sort
of normal and given and, and, and as existing
independently of us. And what art reminds us is
that in fact, everything that we sense and everything
that we do is part of our mutual engagement
and formation with the world. And I think Hegel
famously doesn't articulate a theory of aesthetic experience the
way Khan does. So, Kant says, you know, it's
the playing of the faculties and that's part of
why it gives us pleasure is because it gives
us a break from our kind of prosaic parsing
of the world Hagel doesn't ever actually say that.
But I think what he implies is that when
we are disrupted, out of our prosaic attitude towards
the world into a more aesthetic attitude towards it,
we're actually sensing truth in a way that we
don't otherwise. So if I go from just seeing
the tree to having an aesthetic experience of the
tree, that's actually a more true experience of the
tree. And that's part of what gives me joy.
So I think that's part of what Hagel thinks
is going on in all kinds of aesthetic pleasure.
So uh there was a point there uh in
my previous question where you mentioned the fact that
at a certain point in his work on aesthetics,
Hegel talks about how humans can take ownership of
their art through specific kinds of art. Could you
tell us a little bit more about that?
Yeah. So this is behind his trajectory from architecture
to sculpture to what he calls or actually it's
one of his um editors. But anyway, the three
romantic arts which are painting music and poetry. So,
and many other philosophers like Herder had put art
into a different trajectory. So I think one really
good way of trying to figure out what Hagel
is up to is to compare those and and
you know, why does he put what at the
top? Um So for Hegel architecture is the art
form that feels most externalized to humans, right? So
it's big in scope. It's also usually functional, although
he often, he also talks about architecture that's not
functional. Um And it, it has to do primarily
with matter that seems independent of humans. So stone
or brick or wood and then sculpture also has
a more um and an externalized material. So whether
that's marble or plaster or whatever, but in sculpture,
at least paradigmatic sculpture as Hagel understands it, humans
start to reflect themselves in it. So paradigmatic sculpture
for Hegel is ancient Greek sculpture where um humans
are no longer making uh like monstrous, exaggerated forms,
but more just straight up human forms. So that's,
that's more attention to the human and more attention
to the subjective. And then when you get to
painting music and poetry, you're increasingly focusing humans attention
on what's going on inside of them as arts
material. So color doesn't, I mean, it's let me
put it this way. It's more obvious to us
that color doesn't exist in the world the way
that stone exists in the world. OK. So Hagel
still doesn't think that we should talk about stone
as existing independently of us. But leaving that aside,
painting more obviously points out to us our involvement
in whatever is painted. And so I already talked
about like perspective, but that's true also of color.
And Hagel likes to talk about how it's possible
for a human to see a form like a
human, not even by drawing, but just by juxtaposing
colors against each other. So even if there isn't
a human form drawn, if you juxtapose the colors,
a human will see a drawing where there isn't
one, right? So again, more activity on the part
of the subject and then music, as I was
saying a minute ago, same thing. Music is totally
interior, right? So there we can't really talk about
any material that's outside, like we can talk about
the instruments, but the instruments aren't the music and
they certainly aren't my experience of the music. So
that's totally interior and then poetry. So Hagel and
this is one of the the interesting differences between
Hagel and other philosophers including Schopenhauer, right? So Schopenhauer
puts music at the top because he wants really
to highlight that kind of subjectivity. But Hagel is
always interested in the unity of identity and difference,
right? So he doesn't want to stop at subjectivity.
He wants to go back to integrating subjectivity back
into objectivity. And so when we get to poetry,
we have um something that's 100% human creation, namely
language as material, but it's, it's not as subjective
as music because language is something that you and
I have to agree on on some level. Otherwise
it wouldn't count as language if I just start,
you know, speaking gibberish, that might be my private
language, but it's not going to function like language
unless I'm in dialogue, literally, not just with one
person, but with a whole culture. So then when
we get to as a kind of poetry, which
then embodies language as this very human creation and
this very mutually formed creation back into action, right?
So then you have characters embodied characters back to
embodiment, embodied characters on a stage using language that's
been mutually agreed upon, not just between individuals but
by a culture. Then Hagel thinks we've got a
really profound experience of collective aesthetic creation that can
unite us as a community while also showcasing the
kind of subjectivity that a character like Antigone or
Hamlet is experiencing. So, um so that's the way
in which Hagel, that's why Hagel orders them the
way he orders them and decides that drama is
the most complete form of aesthetic experience, which does
not. And we'll probably get to this in a
minute. Um Mean that he thinks that it's the
best form of art, but it is the highest
aesthetic experience philosophically for humans.
You know, uh while you were talking, I was
thinking at a certain point because you mentioned Schopenhauer
there that uh if um uh I mean, of
course, you probably already alluded to some of that
in your answer. But uh I was wondering what
extent Hegel's statics also connects to his metaphysics because
when you mentioned Schopenhauer, I mean, Schopenhauer is um
a, at least for us more modern contemporary people,
it's a bit of a weird idea. But uh
if, if I understand it correctly. I think that,
uh OK, so, um Schopenhauer took that division from
Kent, uh the division between the Neuman and, and
the phenomenon and the phenomenons uh the Ninon sorry,
supposedly is what reality itself is. I mean, the
fundamental nature of reality. And uh and this is
also something I, I guess that Nietzsche talks about
in the, the origin of tragedy because back then
in his first book, he was already very much
influenced by Schopenhauer. He then uh uh left some
of that out of his philosophy later on. But
uh didn't Schopenhauer have this sort of idea that
music itself was part of the fundamental nature of
reality.
Yeah. Absolutely. And that, and for Schopenhauer, the reason
we love music so much and the reason it
moves us so much is because it is the
most raw experience of reality we can get. And
uh absolutely, it, it moves us because it is
also, you know, and this is, I think is,
is the kind of thing Hagel thought too that
the joy that we get in it and in
and its immediate access to our emotions so that
music can make us sad about nothing, right? So
it's not if I listen to sad music, I'm
not sad about anything. I'm just sad. That's incredible.
Like the fact that that's possible. Schopenhauer thinks says
something really profound about the nature of reality and
about the nature of being human. And I think
Hagel is attuned to that as well. And it
doesn't be again because he's more interested in thinking
about a society in which people work together. I
mean, Hagel, I sometimes say to my students is
just more interested in like making sure that the
society functions. And so he's, he's much more interested
in saying, OK, what institutions are going to be
necessary for us to create a society in which
humans can live to their full potential. And someone
like Schopenhauer, as I understand him is, is just
much less interested in that. So I think Hagel
wants to pull back from this kind of ra
education of subjectivity and say, OK, it's really good.
It's really important fundamental to modern humans. Now, we've
got to show how it can be fostered within
institutions. And so I think that's part of why
um music doesn't top the list for him and
to your original question about metaphysics. Absolutely. I mean,
this is the structure of reality as far as
Hagel is concerned, the identity of identity and difference.
And so the, the way in which the trajectory
of the arts, including music's subordinate place to drama
into poetry in general is a metaphysical commitment on
Hagel's part. Absolutely.
Uh And uh I mean, you mentioned drama there.
Uh Did Hegel have specific views about tragedy and
comedy?
Yes, this is something I thought about a lot.
Um And probably many of your viewers will know
that Hagel is most famous for talking about tragedy.
So his interpretation of antigone has been in particular,
very influential. And I mean, the thousands of pages
that have been written on that are testament to
how, how important and revelatory his theory of tragedy
was. But um much less attention has been paid
to his theory of comedy. And so I got
really interested in that at a certain point. Um
Both what Hagel says about comedy and why it
has been um not taken as seriously, really quick
answer to the second question that's just really typical
that philosophers um tend to take serious things more
seriously. And unless you want to take comedy seriously
and therefore risk being comic yourself because how ridiculous
is it to take comedy seriously? Um People don't
do it. I, I have uh spent probably more
time in my life than I should taking comedy
very seriously. I teach a course on it. Um
And that, that is in part because I, yeah,
I got interested in what Hagel says about tragedy
and comedy. So in short, and I'm much more
focused on what he says about it in his
lectures on aesthetics rather than what he says in
the phenomenology. But I do think they are, they
are connected tragedy for Hegel shows a kind of
subjectivity, very entrenched in itself and in roles in
particular in like social roles. So if you think
about antigone, she is struggling with her role as
a daughter and as a sister and as a
subject, right? So her brothers have been killed, she
wants to bury one of them. She feels that
that's her duty. Her uncle, the king is also
her king now and she's supposed to obey him
and he forbids this, um, since one of her
brothers was a traitor. So the, the tragedy there
is between two people who are deeply invested in
their subjective relationships to their roles and those roles
are incompatible. So there's no way for it to
end without one of them dying. Um It's not
several people die, but you know, of the two
of them, only one of them dies. And so
I, but in so far as Hegel is always
interested in the unity of unity and division. What
you get there is two people whose conflict with
each other cancels itself out and then what you
get at the end the synthesis. Although Hagel doesn't
use that word is the survival of the Greek
City state with increased knowledge of how those roles
have to be treated within the Polish. So Creon
ends the play essentially admitting that he shouldn't have
had the attitude that he had to his role.
So, so for Hagel, the reason that tragedy is
art is because it shows this clash, which ends
in a kind of unification comedy, also ancient comedy
and Hagel's favorite is Aristophanes also ends in reunification.
But it's because like if you take streps sides
as an example in the clouds, he doesn't take
himself so seriously. So he, you know, kind of
goofs around and he undermines the city and then,
you know, he cheats and he, and he's never
like fixed on his role and that gives him
an enormous amount of power. And so in the
clouds, in particular, you also see the, like the
beginning of the erosion of the idea that the
gods are really in control because they're being mocked
in strips and, and they had been before, this
isn't new in Aristophanes necessarily. But at the end
of that, you get a kind of cheerful reunification.
And Hegel actually says, um at another point, you
know, maybe that's better, you know, why would we
choose the dark and um desperate conflict of tragedy
over the cheerful life affirming? And I think there's
a lot of this in Nietzsche too, life affirming
laughter of someone who doesn't have to be so
beholden to his roles that he's willing to bring
the whole society down around him. So there's a,
there's a, an extended story that I'm happy to
tell if, if you're interested um about how that
changes in modern tragedy and modern comedy. Um But
Hagel is pretty pessimistic about both mo modern tragedy
and modern comedy. Um And essentially, I think, thinks
that we're going to have to transcend both of
them or, and this is another big topic, move
to more of a humor based aesthetic than a
comedy based aesthetic,
right? Uh I'm going to ask you more about
that, about modern comedy and tragedy in a second.
But I, I mean, I just wanted to make
a brief comment because this was to some extent,
I mean, uh the, the way people like Hegel,
Schopenhauer Nietzsche and others in the 19th century approached
uh aesthetics and art uh somewhat reminds me of
uh how dismissive uh the post Socratic were of
the Pres Socratic because the Pre Socratic took the
poets and uh seriously when it comes to uh
I mean, perhaps uh also being able to acquire
some sort of knowledge through art, through fiction and
all of that. And I, and I, and I
mean, of course, I, I don't think we can
really be sure about what part of it came
from Socrates or Plato because sometimes we don't know
for sure if it's Socrates or Plato talking, but
in Plato's works. But anyway, I, I mean, the
Socrates and the, the other Greek philosophers who came
after him were very dismissive of Homer specifically and
the other poets. And when you think about the
Pres Socratic and even what we call the Sophists,
I, I mean, nowadays, sophistry has a very negative
connotation to it, but the Sophists were very much
philosophers themselves, I think. Uh SO I, I wa
I was just, I mean, it just came to
my mind that uh there are, there have been
periods in Western philosophy, where people have very much
been dismissive of art, at least as a potential
source of some kind of knowledge and others where
people really engaged with art seriously and philosophically took
art seriously.
Yeah. Absolutely. Yeah. And I think this is the
19th century, is one place where that pen direction.
So tell us about the issues that Hegel had
with modern forms of art, particularly uh with what
we could call, I guess modern subjectivity in art
because uh as time went on and particularly since
the, I guess, more or less the 19th century
onwards, I mean, in literature and other forms of
art, we see people focusing more on particular characters
and character development and there's objectivity even what goes
on in their minds through ex through lots and
lots of, of, of texts sometimes just focusing on
their inner thoughts and all of that. II, I
guess that's what we could call a modern subjectivity
in art to uh or perhaps there's also some
other forms of subjectivity. But what did Hegel think
about it?
I think one of the best places to isolate
that is in what he says about humor. And
yeah, and I think humor was a really new
aesthetic phenomenon. It essentially began with Lawrence Stern's Tristam
Shandy, which was enormously popular in Germany. I mean,
Goethe and Schiller and Lessing and anybody who was
anybody um loved Stern and his evocation of characters
who were not comic in the classic sense of
like, Aristophanes. Um, BUT were kind of quirky and
had foibles and eccentricities that made you kind of
gently laugh at them. So, not mock them, not
guffaw but, but just recognize how much humans get
obsessed with what stern called their hobby horses. Like
their little things that they're, the, the little things
that they wanna be obsessed about. So, you know,
whether it's your train set or his, you know,
his uncle's military, uh what was it? It wasn't
exactly a like models, I guess. Anyway, um So
Hagel thought that comedy and, and humor needed to
be differentiated as, as did um pretty much everybody
in his um generation. So comedy as a kind
of dramatic art form and humor as something that
more suffused literature and poetry and that highlighted again
this sense that what is really important to pay
attention to among humans now is that since we've
discovered as it were that we are the source
of meaning in the world, what is meaningful to
us and how kind of adorably silly that often
is like how adorably silly many of our concerns
are. And I think Hegel thought that was really
valuable aesthetically because it brought attention to, you know,
the the concerns of art are no longer the
gods or big battles or even like sublime landscapes,
but like Dutch genre paintings or still lifes that
show tiny little involved human obsessions with flowers or
having your tooth pulled or, you know, like everyday
human things, but he did not like it when
people became so subjective that they didn't try to
extract any larger meaning from whatever it was that
they were doing. So he was very critical of
Jean Paul Richter on this point, very critical of
people like Schlegel, Friedrich Schlegel. And you know, to
a lesser extent, people like Novalis who Hagel thought
were way too focused on their own interiority and
stream of consciousness essentially as you were just describing
and therefore, again, never made the connection back from
subjectivity back into objectivity and therefore, were not giving
their audiences an experience of the truth. So that's
always what's at stake for Hagel. Um So he's
very critical of what he calls subjective humor and
very admiring of what he calls objective humor.
Do you think that Hagel would have been a,
a fan? Or at least like to some extent
the existentialists, do you think that Hegel would have
been a, a fan or at least like to
some extent the existentialists?
I'm not so sure he would have been to
be honest with you. I think he, he, as
I said earlier, he was really interested in making
a society function on an institutional level. So what
kind of form of government do we need? What
kind of um social order, what kind of economic
order, what kind of family situation and in so
far as existentialists and this is generalizing but often
emphasize the subject in opposition to those things. I
think Hagel would have again, felt like, well, but
what we're after here is truth, which is the
unity of unity and division, not just division. And
we have a world to run like it's our
responsibility to run this world. There's no God out
there to help us out, there's no natural order
like we've got to get this right. And if
there's, and again, this is to caricature. But if
existentialists are sometimes seen as self obsessed or just
as oppositional to the order, I think Hagel would
have been much more interested in reforming the order
in ways that would better allow humans to be
free and the way he thought humans needed to
be free. And that back to something we were
saying a minute ago, I think this is something
that Marx picks up from. Hagel is very much
about what kind of material conditions do humans need
in order to be free. So it's not enough
to say as Kant did um that you're free
if you're self determining and can act against your
inclinations in accordance with the categorical imperative. I realize
that Kant scholars are going to say that that's
not all he meant. And, and I accept that,
but Hagel was much more explicit in trying to
say what real freedom means is paying attention to
what people need in institutions around them. And you
know, just life forms around them in order to
be, to flourish as humans with dignity and respect.
So again, that's maybe too hard on the existentialist.
But I, I think that might be his general
take.
That's very interesting because o of course, we know
that Marx was influenced by Hegel to some extent,
but sometimes because people have these simplistic views of
Hegel and Marx they think, oh, how could it
be? Because Hegel was supposedly a big idealist and
Marx was a me realist. I mean, how could
they be more opposite? But uh I mean, what
you mentioned there and uh Hegel caring very much
about how we structure society, about the institutions we
create and how we create them based on what
values, I guess. Uh I mean, it's very much
uh I guess also applied philosophy or political philosophy
as some of what Marx also cared about.
Absolutely. And I, you know, I think another thing
that you can find in Hegel that I think
is just much more clearly articulated in Marx is
that freedom can be a kind of ideological lie
if you continue to tell people that they're free
as a way of distracting them from the fact
that they're being exploited and alienated, right? So if
you make people focus on, yes, but I'm a
free and determining being because I can follow the
categorical imperative, which I, I again, that's a caricature.
Um Then people are going to feel like, well,
you know, who cares what sort of deprived economic
situation I live in. I'm still free and Hagel,
I think, worried that that kind, that, that kind
of idea could fall into the wrong hands of
people who knew how to manipulate it. Such that
exactly as you said, you know, you can be
a, a worker who's being totally exploited. But as
long as you're told that there's a kind of
freedom that exists in transcending that or not caring
about it or, or that actually, you know what
it is to be human is to, to subsist
despite the struggle of economic depravity, I think Hagel
also would say that's just, that's manipulative, it's deceitful
and it's unethical. Uh IT'S, it's, it is not,
it is false freedom, it is empty, fake, false
freedom. And it can be a kind of uh
a tool in the hands of people who want
to manipulate others into ignoring the ways in which
they're being exploited,
which is very interesting because I guess that this
is also another idea that people do not tend
at all to associate with Hegel. But as Marx,
he also cared about the poverty, right? And about
the causes of poverty and the potential effects it
would have on people's behavior. Correct.
Yeah. So this is specifically in the passages where
he talks about what's called the rabble. And, and
I think this is again, a distinction that Marx
picks up on that what Hagel means by the
rabble is not just people who are impoverished. So
and Hagel, like many people thinks that there will
always be poverty. But what's new since, you know,
well, not new now, but new since the modern
world essentially is the claim that all humans are
worthy of dignity and respect and the acknowledgement or
just the fact that our economies are human creations.
So whereas poverty before could be explained just by
natural phenomenon or just by a hierarchy that we
were told was natural. You know, the king gets
to be rich and you have to be poor
because God made him the king and made you
a pauper. Now, the combination of the claim that
all humans are worthy of dignity and respect and
a human created economy, that means that many people
live in total depravity generates a kind of rage
on the part of what Hagel then calls the
rabble. Um THAT is entirely justified and that Hagel
sees as a pretty existential threat to modern society
because they're right, right. It's, it's not that we
need them to get over this fact that they're
right about it. And as long as that's true,
they, you know, society will be unstable because they
will correctly demand the material conditions. For the thing
that they're told is their kind of existential, right.
So in HGL talks about ways to solve that
through essentially what we would call labor unions or
other forms within civil society that would and within
the government that would represent not just geographical interests
but economic interests. So when, when you look at
what Hagel says about the form the state should
take, I think one of the most overlooked facts
is that he does not want purely geographical representation.
He doesn't want, you know, Prussia gets two delegates
and Bavaria gets two delegates and no following is
two delegates but that different classes and different kinds
of um of industry get representation. So that to
me is very clear evidence that he was worried
about not just the material conditions of capitalism, but
also the questions of identity and self-respect that are
necessary in the modern work world um that are
essentially trampled on by capitalism.
And so um could we say that Hegel like
Marx was also or thought that it was a
moral imperative for society to try as best as
we could to alleviate or ideally eradicate poverty?
Yeah, absolutely. I I don't think Hale thought it
could be completely eradicated. But um yeah, I there's
no question in my mind that he saw this
as the deepest and most insidious kind of hypocrisy
that a society would say on the one hand
that everyone is equal and deserving of dignity and
respect and then continue to choose um an an
economic system that made that a joke, right? And
it's very bad joke, a sad joke. Um It
made it laughable in the worst possible way. And
that a society that continues down that road is
both morally responsible and in danger of instability. So
I do, I do think Hagel thinks those two
things are separate. So a better functioning society is
going to be 11 with less inequality. But also
that totally aside, just as a moral issue. Um
YEAH, this is a classic failure
and just to be totally clear because at a
certain point there, you mentioned the fact that some
of these ideas stem from the more general idea
that people, individual, people themselves have intrinsic value. I
mean, this is not just a matter of caring
about alleviating poverty with the long term success of
a particular society in mind, but also caring actually
about the individuals themselves and the conditions they live
in.
Yes and their emotional and effective attachment to their
value as workers. So when he starts to talk
about solutions to this kind of poverty, he says,
you know, you can certainly get government agencies involved
in essentially welfare, but that's not going to fix
the problem of self-respect. You have to give people
the possibility of having dignity in their work if
work is going to be such a central part
of existence in a capitalist system. Um And so
yeah, ju I mean, just trying to eradicate it
through philanthropy is also not going to fix the
problem. It has to come at the level of
actually valuing workers in their roles as workers.
Oh my God. So it was not just that
Marx was an alien but Hagel was also a
Marxist.
Well, not everybody would agree with me. But, but,
yeah, I mean, I, I think that's all, that's
all very clear to me. Um, THAT, that is
part of what Hagel was concerned about and, you
know, there are places in his philosophy where he
is also guilty of that kind of hypocrisy. So
it's not as if he had some sort of
moral genius that allowed him to see that in
other parts of his life. But I, I think
that was one place where he really did see
the dangers that we are living with very presently
now.
Yeah. No, but I mean, I, I made, I
made that sort of a joke but, uh, uh,
I, if, uh, he's, if you didn't mention his
name, just everything you said about poverty and capitalism
that we should structure society and all of that,
I mean, if someone told me it was Marx
to,
I won't believe it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I
think that's true and that would be true until
we started talking about the state. Right. So Hagel
talks about all of this when he's talking about
civil society, which is the middle one of the.
So he talks about the family and civil society
and the state and its, when he starts to
talk about the state that you would no longer
think we were talking about Marx.
Great. So, uh we've already talked here a little
bit about uh comedy, but one of the things
you've also done work on, uh and again, focusing
on uh 19th century German philosophy is how seriously
some of these philosophers took laughter.
Right. Yeah. Or we might say like the laughable
because it, it's so hard to put all of
the things that we laugh at under uh and,
and a lot of things that are laughable, we
don't actually laugh at. So it's, it's a very
thorny um topic. But, but yes, especially around the
time when Hagel was writing. Um AGAIN, people like
Schlegel, um and some of the other more romantic
philosophers like Zolar um were taking this question of
what we laugh at and why or, or what
it means to differentiate between wit and irony and
humor really seriously. And I think that, uh you
know, Lessing was another one who took this very
seriously. Um Eta Hoffman, like the whole constellation of
people who were philosophical, but also writing in literature.
Um And I think again, it comes back to
this question, like, what does it say about humans
that we laugh? And what does it say about
us that we find this whole range of things
either funny or laughable? And what could we determine
about the essence of what it is to be
human by really trying to figure that out? And
if you're someone like Schlegel who thinks that Hegel
is wrong to imagine that we can articulate truth
in philosophy, then you're going to be looking towards
other forms that maybe as Schlegel would sort of
put it gesture at the truth while not articulating
it. Because articulating it is always going to introduce
new categories and therefore new division. So if the
true is the whole, I think Schlegel would say
to Hegel, um any conceptualization is just going to
show the division again. And if you want something
that retains the unity, it has to remain at
the level of affect or something like irony, which
doesn't take itself too seriously and doesn't define things,
but sort of says that things are true through
saying they're opposite or says something that's witty in
a way that you don't take literally, but you
see the truth behind it. Um So all of
these are ways in which a whole range of
people in the romantic generation decided that if we
could understand that and the way that functions in
the way humans interact with each other and lead
our aesthetic lives, then we could probably understand something
much deeper about humans themselves and about metaphysics quite
honestly. Um So there's a lot of um I
edited a volume of essays about uh humor in
the 19th century. And as I say in the
introduction, usually when I tell people that they laugh
because um one of the things we laugh at
is incongruity and it feels so incongruous to talk
about humor in this generation of very serious philosophers,
but it is something they took really seriously.
And I mean, trying to understand something about our
human nature through laughter. I mean, there are many
different ways we can try to understand it. Right.
And I mean, even philosophers themselves, many different philosophers
across history uh have had different theories about why
people laugh at something. And, uh, I, I mean,
perhaps all of them are true. I don't know
because some, we laugh at different things in different
contexts for different reasons. I mean, sometimes we might
laugh at something because it's funny and why it's
funny is an entire question by itself. But uh
sometimes perhaps people laugh at someone to mock them.
Not exactly because it's funny, but just to mock
them or to feel superior to other people, perhaps
something, someone does something wrong. Uh And they are,
I mean, competing with them and then the other
person laughs just because, oh, you made the mistake.
So I'm in a, in a better situation than
you are or something like that. So, I mean,
the, uh just thinking about laughter itself and the
many different contexts and reasons why people laugh is,
uh, I mean, it's, it's a very wide uh
field of inquiry, I guess.
Yeah, absolutely. Yeah.
OK. So, um let's get now into uh how
you got interested in abolitionism in America in the
19th century. So, tell us first about that. What
got you interested in that and then we'll get
into the work of Lydia Maria Child.
Yeah, this was, um, a very direct response on
my part to the 2016 election in the United
States. So when, when Donald Trump was elected, um
it became very clear to many of us that
we were in a kind of moral and political
emergency. Uh So the real resurgence of a kind
of far right, political stance and all of the
other things that Trump represented, including his um just
open derision of and abuse of women. And I
think as a Hagel scholar, I've always had to
grapple a little bit with what, how I felt
when I would read Hagel scholarship from the 19
thirties. And I would always have in the back
of my mind, what did this person think they
were doing? Um WAS what they were doing more
important than anything they could have been doing to
fight the rise of fascism in Germany. Um And
I don't pretend I don't mean to be judgmental.
I'm sure people have all kinds of reasons, et
cetera, but I just had a very clear sense
very quickly that I needed my professional life and
my scholarship to reflect the time that I was
living in. And I had a, I wanted to
know who in my own country and in my
own history. Um I could turn to as an
example of someone who had faced a moral emergency
in their country. Head on. And I just decided
I wanted to turn to women. I'd spent 20
years of my career really exclusively focusing on men.
And so I, I asked myself to fight something
as entrenched as enslavement was in the United States
in the 19th century. I just thought you'd have
to be thinking philosophically, you'd have to be asking
big questions like, what is equality, what is justice?
What does it mean to be a human? What
is moral obligation? Um So I went to an
archive associated with Harvard and that, that is a,
a library and an archive specifically about women and
asked if they knew of any women with a
kind of philosophical uh trajectory who had been involved
in abolitionism and they didn't. But they gave me
a box of letters that included a letter by
this woman who I'd never heard of, but um
was immediately just transfixed by her moral vision, her
ability to argue philosophically um and her ability to
dedicate her life to ending entrenched evil in her
country. So I decided to pivot towards doing something
about her. And at first I, I did write
a couple of more academic articles about her. She
was definitely a philosophical thinker. She also talked about
philosophy. She read philosophy, she was very influenced by
German philosophy. Um She regularly cites Schiller and Goethe
and Harrier and John Paul. She mentions Kant, she
mentions Hegel. German philosophy was very popular in the
United States. Um, IN the 18 thirties and forties
when she started writing. So I had a lot
of pretty instant connections to her philosophical thinking. But
what really again got my attention was she wrote
a book in 18 33 and that's almost three
decades before the American Civil War started. So in
18 33 he wrote a book called An Appeal
in Favor of that class of Americans called Africans.
And this, this is just a fire hose of
arguments denouncing all of the bad arguments that Americans
had been using to justify slavery. And I was
so impressed by how she, I think her general
philosophical commitment was to thinking that humans are basically
good, but they're susceptible to bad arguments that appeal
to their selfishness, their self interest, their vanity. And
if you can just clear away those arguments, you
can really get them to reform. I'm not sure
she was right about that. I don't even think
she thought she was right about that by the
end of her life. Um But I became really
fascinated both by her as a philosophical thinker, but
also as a woman whose life intersects in all
of the major moments leading up to and through
the American Civil War. Um She did everything from
put her body between abolitionist speakers and anti abolitionist
mobs. She wrote fiction and also argumentative essays. She
wrote biographies, she wrote histories. Um She volunteered herself
raising money for and sewing for both union soldiers
and, um, enslaved peoples. So she, um, she was,
she is, to me a real example of someone
who took her role as an American citizen seriously
and deployed everything she could think of, uh, to
address what she saw as the great moral crisis
in her country. So I wrote a biography of
her. Um, AGAIN, I, I thought I would just
sort of write academic articles about her, but the
story is so compelling that I ended up writing
the whole thing and that came out um about
six months ago.
Great. Uh And II, I mean, uh we also
have to keep in mind that the 19th century
was not to, to put it mildly very women
friendly and also for the most part, not very
friendly to any person who was not of European
descent, basically in, in terms of the mainstream philosophers,
thinkers, scientists and so on. Uh I mean, of
course, we have to keep also in mind the
cultural context back then. And I, I'm also not
one of those people who, of course, I say
that that they were wrong in terms of their
sexism and racism. But I don't think that if
I lived back then I wouldn't have been racist
and sexist myself, of course, very likely I would
have been one as well and most of us,
I guess so. Uh But I mean, we have
to keep that, keep that in mind but also
the struggle that women and, uh, but, uh African
Americans and other minorities went through and particularly since
we are approaching things here from a philosophical perspective
and I am talking with U as an academic,
I mean, it's historically, it's a fact and even
con temporarily that, uh, women and, uh, other minorities,
uh, I mean, their work has very much been
neglected, sometimes suppressed and, uh, stuff like that. Right.
So, it's, it's not been easy at all for
people who are not European white males and European
white males, particularly from the upper classes to have
their voices heard.
Yeah. Yeah. And, and there's really wonderful work being
done on that. So, um Kristen Yah and Dal
and Nassar just last year published a whole anthology
of work by women philosophers in Germany in the
19th century. And Alison Stone and I are working
on a handbook about British and American women philosophers
in the 19th century. There were many more of
them than we think there were. And they were
often much better known than we think they were.
So, what we're talking about is a combination of,
of course, women didn't have the same opportunities as
men as far as education goes. But they, but
even those who manage to philosophize despite that were
pretty actively repressed and forgotten later, like not in
their lifetimes but later. So, so there's a lot
of really interesting work on that. Um THAT I
I feel very passionate about. And I, I also
think to your other point, it's really important for
us to acknowledge in as much detail as we
can the damage that people like Hagel did on
these topics. So I think even myself as a
woman, I used to just sort of think, well,
of course, he thought women were like plants like
everybody did, but that's not true. There were lots
of people including women who didn't think that, but
there were, he did have options available to him
and even more so on race. So there's a,
there's really important work by Daniel James and Franz
Kopek and um and, and others on what Hagel
probably did know about other ways of thinking about
non European peoples which he deliberately chose to ignore
or suppress. And there's even terrible stories about Hagel.
Hagel's like philosophy of history being used as a
justification in the United States for perpetuating slavery. And,
you know, I was talking earlier about Hagel's ability
to pinpoint hypocrisies um between in a culture that
said on the one hand, all humans are worthy
of dignity and respect. And on the other hand,
subjecting them to capitalism's woes. Obviously, Hagel himself is
horrendously guilty of doing that pretty much with anyone
who wasn't, as you said, an upper class white
European male. Um And I have become much less
willing just to say, wow, OK, that's like a
part of his philosophy, we can ignore um and
much more determined to take that head on and,
and as you say, too importantly, augmented with a
kind of humility that reminds myself as well, that
I'm probably on the wrong side of history on
other things. And that, um if I were living
at Hegel's time, I probably would have had many
opinions that were not very enlightened either. So, to
me, that's part of the, the general project of
thinking about the 19th century is elevating voices like
childs that are um so philosophical and so resonant
and using the same kinds of ideas, including ideas
about art that Hagel was interested in, but really
in the service of good and trying to be
much more mindful and critical of ways in which
Hegel's philosophy is beautiful and compelling as it can
be um was used for evil.
Yeah. Uh I mean, this is another entire discussion
that I think is very interesting that people can
have. I mean, uh and the same applies to
artists. I mean, sometimes people discuss if what we
should do with the work of immoral artists, if
we should ban it, if not, if we, if
we don't ban it, uh we should analyze it.
Uh We should think of it if we should
appreciate it or not and if we should criticize
it, uh I mean, there's uh an immensity of
questions out there that are very interesting about that.
But, but uh uh I mean, of course, Uh
I'm not myself and I don't think you are
some of those people. I think that perhaps we
should be because someone in the 19th century or
the 18th century had some appalling views on women
and uh black people and other minorities that we
should just, uh, I completely ignore or think that
the rest of their work is, doesn't have any
intellectual valid validity at all. But, uh yeah, it's
very much a well established fact that all of
the people we talked about in German philosophy in
the 19th century and Kent was mostly from the
18th century and, and others like them. Uh I,
I mean, I, I it, it's interesting that even
Kent was talking about universal values but apparently they
didn't apply to uh non European people uh curiously
enough. But, but I, I mean, the same thing
I guess happened in other sorts of instances, like,
for example, you have the French revolution and supposedly
everyone should get a vote, everyone should get the
same. But it was just very gradually that the
population in France, uh the adult population got to
AAA right to vote. I mean, first it was
just uh one slice of the male population and
then, and the same in happened in America, I
think, I think that initially it was just the,
the people who, who owned land, I guess whether
the right to vote and then it was, yeah,
all
of that was in flux. For a very long
time here. That's true. And, and the other thing
to bring up, I think in the context of
the French revolution is the Haitian revolution. And the
fact that France absolutely did not want any of
their revolutionary principles to apply to a part of
the world that was primarily inhabited by Black people.
Um So that, that's another classic case of um
of the kind of hypocrisy that I think you're
right. To me, it just feels increasingly important to
acknowledge those problems always and upfront. And in every
part of our discussion of these earlier thinkers, um
and never to treat it as something we can
just sort of mention on the side and then
move on from. Um But I don't think that
ignoring these people is good either because it's important
for us to remember that even people who were
intelligent and progressive in other ways um could make
really horrendous mistakes.
And I, and I guess that I it's not
only important from a sort of ethical standpoint but
also intellectually speaking, I guess it's enriching uh to
uh have a better understanding of how our socio
cultural context can influence and have an impact on
our intellectual work, I guess.
Absolutely. Yeah, we, we need to understand why we
think what we think and understanding thinkers that came
before us is an indispensable part of that for
sure.
A a and also keeping in keeping in mind
that again, people are not disembodied beings and we
live and we not only have a body but
we also live in a particular society in a
particular period of time, in a particular culture, we
have a ton of different in influences and we
are also products of all of that even intellectually.
It's not that we have some sort of reasoning
faculty that, that is impermeable to all of that
and that allow us to get some sort of
glimpse into objective reality as it is.
Yeah. And I, I'll also just say briefly, that's
one of the things that really fascinates me about
child is that she was able in many ways
to transcend and to see beyond what was absolutely
the norm around her. And I'm really fascinated by
that. Um And I, you know, most of your
viewers will know that. Um So she grew up
in Boston, which is in the north and most
northerners now assume that all northerners then were against
slavery. And that's absolutely not true. Absolutely not true.
Many northerners actively resisted the end of slavery in
the South. So she was surrounded by politicians and
educators and journalists and religious leaders who actively preached
that this was an acceptable way for society to
be organized. And somehow she saw beyond it. And
she, you know, she wasn't alone in that. And
I'll also say part of how she knew this
is she actually talked to black people, right? So
she actually listened to the people who were themselves
affected. And once was able to see it from
their point of view, realized that what she was
hearing from the leaders in her society was, was
wrong. So again, I don't mean to suggest that
she had some sort of, as you say, disembodied
um experience, but she was willing to listen in
a way that I take as an inspiration to
those of us who sometimes it's a kind of
occupational hazard for philosophers. We like to look at
things from very high up. And often I think
it takes more of a listening on the ground
to um get real ethical insight into what needs
to happen next.
By the way, at least back in her time,
how influential was her, I mean, in the philosophical
world and more specifically in the abolitionist movement in
the US,
she was very influential. She, she was one of
the most famous abolitionists um of the 19th century.
And, and part of what's so interesting about her
is that she was famous before. She became an
abolitionist because she um almost unheard of in the
American 19th century by the age of 22 which
would have been, you know, in the mid 18
twenties, was a very well known novelist and a
self sufficient female author. And she'd written a couple
novels and a couple of self-help books, um like
cooking books or books about parenting or housekeeping um
that had made her really beloved and trusted along
among a great swath. I mean, she was the
19th century equivalent of a household name. Um And
when she became an abolitionist, that was so upsetting
to her readers because it really meant that she
was a radical because to be, to be an
abolitionist in the 18 twenties and thirties in the
United States was to argue for the immediate end
of slavery without compensation to enslavers and most Americans
in the North and the South thought that that
was just unthinkably radical. Um But she, that's what
she was convinced. And, you know, by the time
she was about 30 she continued to be one
of the best published and most um public facing
intellectuals of the 19th century. And certainly in the
abolitionist movement as far as her involvement in the
philosophical community, it's interesting, I mean, there wasn't so
much like philosophical tradition in the United States except
really for the one that was getting going again
in Boston around Ralph Waldo Emerson. And they did
know each other. They were almost exact contemporaries and
she was admiring and would go to his lectures.
Um But also was always concerned that he was
allowing the abstraction of his thought to distract him
from what she thought he should be doing, which
was fighting slavery. So she'd sometimes say he has
a platform big enough and a mind capacious enough
really to make arguments against slavery and he's not
doing it. Um Emerson did come around to doing
that but only in 18 59 when John Brown's
failed insurrection in Virginia uh convinced him that slavery
needed to be um opposed. So she, she certainly
knew all of the philosophers in the Boston area
of her time and socialized with them, communicated with
them, but I think she feared that they had
disengaged themselves from the moral topics of their day.
Too much.
OK. So uh I, I'm also getting mindful of
your time now. So let me ask you, let
me ask you one last question. Uh And let
me see if, if I can phrase this correctly.
So, uh and be clear about it. Uh So,
uh I mean, there are some parts of philosophy
that are politically motivated, like for example, abolitionism is
a very clear example of that. And there are
people that tend to be a little bit dismissive
of philosophy that is done while politically motivated. And
usually those people from come from political positions that
are opposite to the, to the ones that they
say are not valid philosophy, of course. So the
question I wanted to ask you then is how
do you look at the place of a movement
like abolitionism uh in the broader historical context of
philosophy? And uh uh I mean, when it comes
to how people look again at politically motivated philosophy,
I mean, to what extent do you think we
should take it seriously? And, I mean, what do
you think basically about those people's position, the positions
that, oh, I, I mean, philosophy should be about,
I don't know people in academia. I, I mean,
it's, uh, transmitting knowledge to students shouldn't be about,
uh, turning them into activists or something like that.
So, uh, I, I mean, I, I hope I'm
being clear in terms of the question I'm asking
here. But what are your thoughts on it?
Yeah, thank you. It's such a, it's such an
important question to me uh now, so I appreciate
the chance to think about it. Um I guess
a couple of things, first of all, philosophy has
not always been removed from reality. And I think
like the story of the 19th century into the
20th century uh is much more about philosophy deciding
to extract itself from practice. And there are historical
reasons for that, but I think we're wrong if
we assume and I this isn't what you were
saying either. But I think some of the people
you're thinking about would say this, that, that real
philosophy shouldn't dirty its hands or shouldn't kind of
get involved in the world because then it's not
as pure, that's, that's a choice that philosophy has
made relatively recently as a discipline and it has
to do with the professionalization of philosophy um in
the 19th century, in the United States. Well, the
three cases I know most about are the US,
the UK and Germany, you, you couldn't get a
degree in philosophy no matter who you were in
for a long time. Right. Phd. S weren't invented
that long ago and even after they were invented,
they weren't necessary to philosophizing philosophical journals did not
use to require that you came from. Um, YOU
had a phd in philosophy to publish. So, so
the, the professionalization of philosophy has meant that what
it means to do philosophy has gotten narrower and
narrower and narrower, more elitist, more professionalized. But there's
a very long history of philosophy being born out
of grappling with the real world as it were.
Um And I don't think there's been a social
movement in history that hasn't required people to think
philosophically. Um I mean, Angela Davis is a great
example of someone who uh was doing a phd
in philosophy before she became an activist and brought
her um studies in Spinoza and Kant and Hegel
to her struggle for racial justice in the United
States. But I think pretty much anywhere you look,
you would find people who are fighting for justice
thinking philosophically. And I've been very happy to see
people emphasizing that more. So people are writing about
Martin Luther King as a philosopher for instance. Um
And yeah, I was going to say that perhaps
another excellent example would be the civil rights movement
in the 19 sixties and seventies. Yeah,
exactly. So, so I think a, a more or
an alternate model and I think in some ways,
a truer model to philosophy's history is that when
people are confronted with injustices, they have to ask
those bigger questions. And I think what philosophy can
do to empower us is to give us some
clarity about those questions. So, you know, really what
is justice? Um YOU know, we can go back
to the Republic to find people trying to figure
that out. And so when I teach philosophy, I
don't at all think of myself as trying to
turn my students into activists. But I do think
that I want them to see that philosophy can
be a really powerful and even essential tool for
understanding the terms of our debates and the kinds
of things we want to fight for and then
giving us the clarity of thought that can motivate
action. So when, when I think about the way
movements work, sometimes what happens is people just aren't
particularly clear what they're fighting for and why and
what that means is that whenever there's infighting or
tension or unclear, like you can just lose focus
and get, you know, distracted by the details. But
the better you are at saying no, I thought
this through philosophically, even if you don't phrase it
that way. This is what is important, this is
what back to Hagel really creating a society in
which people can truly be free and not just
abstractly free. This is what it would look like
that that is empowering and motivating in a way
that can help us stave off the kind of
burnout or fatalism that is all too often the
death of movements for justice. So I would prefer
to think philosophy is as something that is born
out of humans, just trying to figure our way
out in the world. And the more those of
us who are inclined to think philosophically can articulate
those thoughts and help people think them through. I
think the better chance philosophy has of actually fulfilling
a good purpose in the world.
Yeah, a and perhaps, I mean, people who might
be worried uh about keeping some of the philosophical
traditions of the West, perhaps they should also keep
in mind that if Plato is the father of
Western philosophy, then he wrote a book titled The
Republic, which which I I it would be very
hard to argue that it's not politically motivated because
it's literally a book about how to, to, to
structure politically a society from top to bottom. So,
yeah,
very good. Yeah, absolutely. And the more I think
we recognize that philosophy has been done in many
different ways. So like the academic article really new,
I mean, we think about like Plato writing and
dialogues and Aristotle giving lectures and you know, k
writing something more that we recognize as philosophy, but
people writing philosophically through literature, Nietzsche through aphorisms, like
many of our most important philosophers have been really
disruptive of what people thought philosophy was. And so
I, I do not feel like my time is
well spent fighting for a version of philosophy that
I think is pretty historically contingent, sometimes harmful and
not where the real energy of philosophy should be
great. So, uh let's wrap up the interview here
then uh just before we go and by the
way, I'm also leaving a link in the description
box to your book Lydia on Lydia Maria Child.
Uh AND apart from the book, would you like
to tell people where they can find you and
your work on the internet?
Yes, thank you. I do have a website which
is just Lydia Moland dot com. And I am
also on Twitter. I think that's Lydia underscore Moland
and I have maybe two things on Instagram. So
I'm not, uh I'm not, never been a big
social media person. I'm getting my dipping my toes
in a little bit, but um Twitter is where
I post the most and I do try to
keep the website updated. So people are more interested
in in any of my writing. Um All of
my writing is listed on the website and what
I'm working on now is um findable on Twitter.
Ok, great. So, Doctor Molan, thank you very much
for your time and it's been a real pleasure
to talk to you.
Likewise. Thanks for your very insightful and detailed questions.
I really enjoyed it.
Hi guys. Thank you. For watching this interview until
the end. If you liked it, please do not
forget to like it, share, comment and subscribe. And
if you like more generally, what I'm doing, please
consider support the show on Patreon or paypal. You
have all of the links in the description of
this interview. This show is brought to you by
en lights learning and development done differently. Check their
website at alights dot com. I would also like
to give a huge thank you to my main
patrons and paypal supporters per Larson Jerry Mueller and
Frederick Sunda Bernards, all of election and Weser, Adam
Castle Matthew Whitting Whitting Bear. No wolf, Tim Hoy,
Eric, Alania, John Connors, Philip Forrest, Connelly, Robert Winde
Ruin. Nai Zoup, Mark Nevs Colin Holbrook, Simon Columbus,
Phil Kor Michael Stormer, Samuel Andreev for the S
Alexander Dan Bauer Fergal Ken Hall, her OG Michel
Jonathan. Lebron Jars and the Samuel K Eric Heins,
Mark Smith, Jan Wera Amal Sran David Sloan Wilson
Yasa, Des Roma Roach Diego JP Dr Man, NCO
Bar. We and Pao Assy Naw Guy Madison Gary
GH. Some of the Adrian Yin Nick Golden Paul
talent in Ju Bar was Julian Price Edward Hall
Eden Bronner, Douglas Fry Franca Bertolotti Gabriel Pan Cortez,
Lelis Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Duffy, Sonny Smith, John
Wiesman, Martin Aland, Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul George
Arnold Luke Lo A Georges the often Chris Williamson,
Peter Oren David Williams, the Costa Anton Erickson Charles
Murray, Alex. Shaw and Murray Martinez Chevalier, Bangalore atheists,
Larry Daley Junior, Holt Eric B. Starry Michael Bailey.
Then Sperber, Robert Grassy Rough the RP MD. Ior
Jeff mcmahon, Jake Zul Barnabas Radix, Mark Campbell, Richard
Bowen Thomas the Dauber Luke Ni Andre story, Manuel
Oliveira, Kimberly Johnson and Benjamin Gilbert. A special thanks
to my producers is our web gem Frank Luca,
Tom Weam Bernard Ni Ortiz Dixon Benedict Mueller, Vege,
Gli Thomas Trumble, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John Carlo
Montenegro, Robert Lewis and Al Nick Ortiz. And to
my executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Serge Adrian and Bogdan
Kut. Thank you for all.